I understand that those that are
unbanked are obviously in worse
economies they make two dollars a day
however what I will say is the great
thing about blockchain technology
Bitcoin aside was the fact that it does
put people on the financial map but what
that means is it means that it opens up
the global economy and so those people
who are only earning two dollars a day
within their own economy now are on the
financial map and have the ability to
earn so much more by doing business with
the rest of the world as an example I
needed somebody to redo my website the
guy in the US was going to charge me I
think five or seven thousand dollars I
hired somebody I can't remember maybe he
was in Pakistan I gave him a thousand
dollars for it now he can be competitive
right he can now compete he makes more
money he makes more money since I'm base
here he's working with people based in
America as opposed to People based on
his own country who will only pay him
you know two dollars a day